what you need to know this wednesday
begins in cleveland where there's a lot
of little things coming out of the
browns mandatory mini camp and
duke johnson third round draft pick a
few years ago by the cleveland browns he
wants out because he's stuck behind nick
chubb and eventually kareem hunt and
it's clear that he wants out
and
he's at the mandatory mini camp because
he doesn't want to have to pay 88 000
plus to skip the three-day mini camp but
he wants to be traded baker mayfield
quarterback of the browns and
unquestioned team leader addressed the
duke johnson situation when he spoke to
reporters yesterday here's what baker
mayfield had to say
that's something that we've been dealing
with for a while
you know if we have guys that want to be
here they'll show that they'll voice
that obviously you know he's going to
handle his stuff how he wants
but
you're either on this train or you're
not it's moving you can get out the way
or you can join us so
it is what it is
here's the thing though duke johnson
wants to get out of the way right yeah
he wants to be traded he doesn't want to
be there later in the day freddie
kitchen's the coach of the team talking
to reporters about gerald mccord joining
the panthers he said we want guys who
want to be here okay fine then trade
duke johnson you can't reconcile on one
hand baker mayfield saying hey
you know join us or get out of the way
and not letting duke johnson get out of
the way and i know that there's a
strategic effort here to try to get
value for duke johnson or keep him
around because all it takes is one falls
move from nick chubb and duke johnson's
up
but
yes he wants to go so it's a strong
message from baker mayfield
but it ignores the reality that duke
johnson doesn't want to be there yeah
well you're right it does ignore the
reality and but the reality is the
cleveland browns want to jock duke
johnson right now that's the reality and
duke johnson's not in a position to be
able to call his shot right now
especially he's not that type of a
player first of all to where he's going
to kind of create a media frenzy around
him and people are going to be oh my
gosh duke johnson wants out of the
cleveland browns no he's a good player
but not a star or anything like that but
the ultimate point is this mike that you
know i think he's crazy for wanting to
be traded right now nick chubb's the
only guy he's got to worry about yes
kareem hunt's going to be there during
otas and training camp man that's going
to make practice better for you duke
johnson but the first eight weeks of the
year kareem hunt won't be there they
don't have that third down pass catching
back on their offensive roster right now
he is that guy so he really can be set
up to have a hell of a year the first
eight weeks of the year and we'll see
where kareem hun is at that point maybe
he's trade bait at that point i don't
know but i think he is a little early
here in calling his shot for the trade
because i i do believe that he's going
to have a nice little role within this
football team and in this offense
because they don't have anybody else at
the running back position that that
fills the need that he does is that
third down versatile pass catching back
yeah and look he's already gotten his
second contract from the cleveland
browns so this isn't about setting
himself up to get paid right
i just think that he feels marginalized
by the arrival of kareem hunt and the
the uh the rise of nick chubb and i
think that he sees the handwritings on
the wall at some point they're going to
decide we don't need duke johnson he's
trying to push that before it gets to
that point so he can land somewhere else
where he can make the team and justify
his salary i'm looking at what he's due
to make over the next few years 1.8
million this year that's not all that
much but he's going to have to get
himself in a spot where he justifies a
3.6 million dollar salary in 2020 and
4.65 million in 2021. that's a lot for
running backs when there are a lot of
guys out there you can draft and pay six
figures to i think this is why he's
trying to push this he wants to have a
chance to earn his money in 2020 and
2021 the browns aren't going to keep him
for that and he's going to have to go
out and scrounge around for the best
offer he can find whereas if he goes to
a team where he can make an impact this
year maybe they happily pay him 3.6
million next year especially if they
gave something up to get him now yeah
those are those are all valid points i
mean
you mean you're right i'm not going to
argue against any of those only thing
i'd argue against is that duke johnson
you're you're a part of a hell of an
offense right now that's got a lot of
talent and you can kind of be the under
the radar nobody's thinking about you
guy on that offense that can maybe
benefit from having so much talent
around you and like i said previously
the fact that there is no guy on the
roster that does the things duke johnson
does coming out of the backfield
especially in the past game where he
might be able to rack up enough stats
and carve out enough of a
niche for himself in that offense in the
first eight weeks of the year to where a
kareem hunt comes back we don't expect
him to be like totally a 100 kareem hunt
right right away in week nine so duke
johnson's still gonna have that role and
if things are going really well they're
not going to just be like oh kareem
hunts back the hell with you duke
johnson get off the field no he's going
to continue that role and set himself up
really for probably a trade in the
offseason however it goes with kareem
hunt or maybe he does get released and
has the stats that can justify the kind
of money you're talking about for that
2020 season to where he signs somewhere
else as a free agent and cleveland does
ultimately uh cut him so i'm just saying
cleveland's not the worst scenario for
this guy
for this year yeah but i think the play
is 20 20. that's the key right doing
enough this year so somebody wants you
at those higher salaries in 2020 and
2021.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports